hi i'm zach pitko and i'll be talking
about rational thoughts in neural codes
thank you for the invitation to
participate in this workshop on
integrating theories of the brain
there are two sessions
one on data driven or ai approaches to
integrating theory and the other
theory driven or mechanism
i'm more of a both and kind of guy
so the work that i'll be telling you
about today is relating the two
you have some data driven components
some artificial intelligence components
it's all driven by theory and it has
implications for mechanisms
how to think about them so the overview
is i'll tell you about this perspective
or framework on rational control and by
rational we mean
the wrong actions but for the right
reasons
i'll talk about equivalences of
generating those actions different ways
that you can create the same
computations
and the implications of that for how we
should analyze neural data in light of a
theory
about these equivalences and how that
should affect latent dynamics and what
we should look for
so let's begin
so here's the brain uh and oftentimes in
neuroscience we
relate measured activity in the brain to
measured things in the world which
includes sensory information and motor
information
but a lot of the stuff that's happening
in the brain is actually
not
sensory or motor but something in
between and we don't really yet know
well how to characterize that so we
could call that thoughts so how could we
measure a thought such that we can
relate that measurement to brain
activity and understand
the consequences and the implications
for
how the brain implements those thoughts
well we start with the idea that the
brain has a model of the world and the
world is evolving over time maybe not
complete and completely in concordance
with the brain's model but there is a
state of the world that evolves
and we don't as brains get to perfectly
understand or know that world scene we
only get indirect observations and that
leaves us with a lot of ambiguity
we can use those observations to
generate beliefs about the world
and those beliefs evolve over time as we
gather new information
now the world is structured and we know
that the world is structured and we
exploit some of that structure and here
that structure is manifested graphically
as having some arrows some causal arrows
for what variables influence what other
variables later in in time so you can
see that the arrows point kind of down
for these two top circles and
up from the bottom back to the top and
this leads to a kind of circulation this
is a cartoon of one causal structure
that you might see
now our brain may have a parallel
structure
in good cases it would know the
structure of the world and maybe it
makes some erroneous assumptions about
the way the world works
and our observations as we parse them by
our brain tissue is
divided into things that are relevant
for different aspects of the world that
we see and so that informs our beliefs
now the world is stochastic and that
means that there's a lot of uncertainty
about what we're actually seeing and how
the dynamics evolve that we don't get
perfect information about
and that means that our beliefs are not
just a copy of the world state
but instead should capture multiple
numbers per variable of interest and
that would be something like a best
guess plus your uncertainty about it and
there might be joint uncertainty so
there's there's more numbers that the
brain has to use has to represent in
order to capture the dynamics of the
world than just the variables it's
capturing
the world is also non-linear the
dynamics and updates of the world are
complicated and although it might be
that in some cases the brain tries to
update its world estimates
in in one step
it's easier for the brain using its
actual hardware
and the mechanisms that it has available
to update them in multiple steps using
intermediate or auxiliary variables
that are
represented in some other neural
populations or maybe in the very same
population just in different dimensions
so this is going on over time
there's also no reason that the number
of neurons that you need
to compute is the same as the number of
beliefs that you have so there might be
a distributed code with in fact there's
lots of evidence that there is
the information is distributed across
many neurons
and so the dynamics of all of these
neurons that there may not be any
beliefs explicitly anywhere but it may
be just implicit in these populations
this is the the metaphor that i like to
think about
and so
now as you're going along and updating
these belief dynamics implicitly in the
populations those are driving actions
so the the behavioral model that we use
to describe what we're thinking
is based on a belief but causally
speaking really what's going on is that
of course the neurons are driving the
actions
but
we find it very convenient and
theoretically helpful to consider that
the beliefs are driving the actions and
we just know that those beliefs are
implemented by a bunch of neurons
so our our overall hypothesis here is
that there are latent variables about
the world in fact probabilistic ones
that are distributed across neurons and
they perform implicit inference and
select actions through the nonlinear
dynamics and those nonlinear dynamics
pertain to the beliefs that we have
about the world
now
if you go back over 100 years helmholtz
proposed that our brain is performing
unconscious inference
and the implication of that and of many
others theories
is that there's a match between the
brain and the world
that's been really fruitful as a way of
generating hypotheses about the world
and generating testable predictions and
sometimes the brain is in fact very
close to optimal which is remarkable and
marvelous but many other times the brain
falls short of what we would consider to
be optimal
and we know from plenty of experience
with human foibles how true that is
so
how then do we get any guidance from
theory if the theory tells us the best
thing to do there are so many ways to be
wrong what kind of guidance could we get
well what if the agent in this case the
brain or an animal is wrong but
rational
that means doing the wrong things but
for the right reasons
have some justification for what's going
on and we can rationalize those actions
as being
right under the wrong assumptions
so we developed a framework to formalize
this idea which we call inverse rational
control
and so we assume that the agent is
optimal but under some subjective
assumptions which may not match whatever
experiment they're being measured in
then we observe the agent's actions
and the sensory observations of the
agent
and we estimate a model
theta for the dynamics the uncertainties
the rewards the action costs all the
assumptions that the animal has about
the world
along the way we have to infer the
latent beliefs
that dictate those actions
and we put all that together to come up
with a marginal likelihood
over the observations and actions that
we see given the model and we optimize
that marginal likelihood over models
in other words
we parameterize agents by the task that
they solve best
and then we solve for all possible
policies within that task family so for
each family member theta some tasks and
assumptions we come up with the policy i
for choosing the actions from a given
belief
and again given the
given the model given the assumptions we
then use that policy to compute a
likelihood over the sensory data and
that gives us a likelihood over all
tasks which we then maximize to find the
best interpretation of animal behavior
as rational that is optimal under the
assumptions of theta
and we've shown for simulated agents
that this successfully recovers false
belief so for example in this
publication um that's listed down below
we have an agent who's foraging between
a couple of boxes
choosing when to look in the box for
food and making sensory observations
about the likely quality of the box
along the way the true agent that we've
simulated has some real beliefs which
are shown in blue
and
we also are able we are also showing
here this gray grayscale in the
background which is our posterior
over those beliefs so our probability
over their probability
and you can see that there's a very nice
agreement between the inferred beliefs
and the actual beliefs of this
suboptimal behaving animal or simulated
animal
so this is very encouraging and we are
now
deeply involved in testing this in
animals in real tasks and hopefully
we'll have some cool results to report
to you in the not too distant future
now
this is all behavior and so what happens
when we start to look inside the brain
which is ultimately the goal here well
we need to have some model
of how that information all that
probabilistic information the beliefs
that the animal has about the world how
they might be manifested in neurons
we're looking for that and we want to
know what properties it has
so one possibility is that we could have
a model with a really clear
correspondence between the factors in
the world and the factors in the brain
groups of neurons would then represent
individual aspects that are driving
these variables or causing those
variables to interact so the circles
here represent variables the squares
represent evidence about those variables
or interactions between those variables
and we have a model that says
how these things should interact if
you're implementing them by population
codes but this right here is really like
a grandmother cell representation
and so it may well be possible or i
would say likely that all of those
things are mushed together into a big
population of over neurons with
overlapping tuning mixed selectivity and
there's a lot of evidence for this
although there is some segregation for
different types of
modalities and different types of
variables as well so now we have this
population partially overlapping groups
of neurons that are encoding things and
they're still circulating information
much in the same way sharing information
to get better estimates and inferences
and
but now it's done at the population
level implicitly in some interacting
projections or interacting high
dimensional patterns of activity
so this becomes complicated how do we
even think about that
and at the same time you might ask well
there there could be multiple ways of
implementing the same computations
and that would be what what we often
call mechanism but there are many
mechanisms that can generate the same
computations
and so to some degree i would advocate
looking for the abstract qualities that
those mechanisms have in common rather
than focusing on the biophysical details
there are some cases where you want to
when you're dealing with interventions
you want to figure out which neurons to
zap or what pharmaceuticals to apply
but oftentimes to understand the
computational function it's good to take
this more abstract view so for example
here we might have a quadratic function
a square that we want to apply to some
information that's represented by a
population of neurons here
and you could implement that square by a
bunch of quadratic products of these
neurons
and then sum those together to get an
estimate but equivalently you can have a
bunch of
threshold linear units that you just add
together and if you uniformly distribute
their thresholds the result is again a
quadratic function
and so i would say in many cases it's
not super important which one of these
is happening in the brain if we want to
understand the computational function
now once we take that perspective where
we're really interested in the task
relevant aspects and this more abstract
property of the mechanism that's going
on then i think it's really helpful to
refer to this neural coding framework of
partially overlapping
processes of encoding recoding and
decoding
so encoding here
refers to how neurons relate to the
stimuli
and decoding is how the neurons derive
their behavior the behavior of the
animal recoding is all the stuff in the
middle where neurons are transforming
their their information
now oftentimes
the decoder is the the experimentalist
or the neuroscientist who's recoding the
neural activity here it's the brain
decoding its own activity and so it's
the same process it's just a different
thing doing the decoding and i think
that this breakdown of encoding recoding
decoding is very helpful
so when we're thinking about that
i like to think about
the task relevant projections or
coordinates in the manifold of neural
activity so neural activity is reduced
uh restricted to some low dimensional
sub subgroups or patterns which we
usually refer to as a manifold
but within that manifold there are
different coordinates some of which are
task relevant like the coordinates at
the top of this kind of smooshed blocks
and some of them are irrelevant like the
green coordinate here
so if we look at this orange line that
orange line is the dynamics of
particular set of task variables during
one task traces out some coordinates in
this belief space
and then orthogonal to that
are all the irrelevant directions and so
the set of irrelevant um
coordinates that all have the same task
relevant coordinates that traces out a
ribbon over time in this case a
one-dimensional
ribbon
and any trajectory within that ribbon
going up and down following the same
orange trajectory is going to give you
the same task performance so here you
see this black line wiggling back and
forth this might be the neural activity
at a population level wiggling around
all consistent with the same task
dynamics
and so i would advocate that this
reduction from the full manifold down to
this task relevant space is really what
we want to think about and understand
for a lot of the computational
properties of what the brain is doing
for these tasks
and so we we tried this perspective on
the simulated data
that i showed you before with the
inverse rational control
and here we have um the encoding of the
beliefs on the horizontal axis which are
predicted from inverse rational control
so this is what our behavioral model
thinks the animal is thinking
and the vertical axis is what we would
predict from the neurons so first
basically we do a regression here we say
okay here is the encoding this is the
dimension or coordinates where that
belief is is represented and then we
cross validate and so the cross
validation shows that you can recover
from these neural projections
a good estimate of the belief predicted
from behavior which is again it's latent
so there's not a ground truth here but
this is a good explanation or
rationalization of the behavior
so then once we have a good estimate
that we say all right we're satisfied
with this encoding model we can then ask
how the dynamics work or the
computations work by looking at the
recoding and this means on the
horizontal axis here we're looking at
the change in the belief which is
predicted from the behavioral model and
then we compare that on the vertical
axis to the change in the belief in the
neural beliefs
that that same coordinate
or set of coordinates according to the
encoding model and you can see there's a
nice diagonal here even within a given
color which is constraining um
to one particular set of observations or
one particular time period so it's not
just that they're
driven solely by the observations but in
fact even within the observations there
are fluctuations going back and forth
based on history and the neural beliefs
match the behavior of the behaviorally
inferred beliefs so this is again a nice
success that you're able to interpret
the neural data in accordance with
this behavioral model and that the
neural dynamics explain or recapitulate
the behavior the inferred behavioral
dynamics or the the inferred latent
beliefs that motivate the behavior
and then finally you can look at the
behavior itself and say how often does
this agent pick different actions
according to the behavioral model and
according to the neural model and again
we get a good agreement here so this is
more encouraging um
suggestion that this type of approach
where you have a good behavioral model
for latent beliefs
or latent dynamics uh and the low
dimensional projection or low
dimensional manifold
that explains the task relevant space
that that can be really fruitful for
understanding real brains so let's see
well that's work for the future
but i'll just conclude here by saying in
summary we presented this framework of
inverse rational control which views the
brain as rational but not optimal and
that gives us theoretical guidance on
the kind of sub-optimality that you
would expect to see in the brain or that
that we can use to interpret the brain
now the mechanisms by which those
computations are performed there are
many
and they could be in lots of different
forms
but we can collapse many of them down to
equivalent computations
and i would say that that's very
satisfactory understanding of what's
going on in the brain
now there are really crucial questions
about generalization and some of these
equivalent computations that are
equivalent for one task may be quite
distinct for another task
and so then that would allow you to test
whether that mechanism is correct by
just looking at a generalization
performance which is a key
challenge in any model of the brain
but once you have this notion of
equivalences you can use dimensionality
reduction or other related techniques to
study the computational dynamics within
that latent variable space that's task
relevant even when that's distributed
across neurons particularly this is
important when the information is
distributed across neurons so we can
find what patterns of collective
behavior collective activity are
responsible for producing that behavior
so that's what i have for you today and
i want to thank all the amazing
scientists who contributed to this
effort uh the inverse rational control
stuff was led by
wu and minhei kwan uh with major
contributions from sarab dr
and this has been a very beautiful
collaboration with paul schrader
for a good period of time and we have a
bunch of experimental collaborators who
have been working on these same tasks
with us and i hope to report soon on
some of the data that we're getting from
their lab and our analyses of it
the neural coding stuff was done by raj
kumar raju and julie
as well as a bunch of other
collaborators that we're trying to apply
that work on and so thank you for your
attention thank you to the funding
agencies who made all this work possible
and if you're interested in applying any
of these frameworks to your stuff
give me a contact give me a call or drop
me a line xaq rice.edu is my email and i
hope to hear from you and i look forward
to the upcoming debate
you